oh it's always fair it's always like oh
this has to be one of one of the most
phenomenal astronomical events that you
can see with your naked eye I mean I'm
just looking at the Sun right now oh
look out a little bit brighter around
the edge
well we're here at the University of
Nottingham in Nottingham but we're
getting ready to jump on a couple planes
to go to China so that we can still be
at the University of Nottingham well
there happens to be a total solar
eclipse that's happening in just a
little over a day and it passes the path
of totality passes right over the
University of Nottingham in Ningbo China
at the moment it looks like it's going
to be cloudy so I'm really really hoping
that the clouds are not with us
forecast looks very grim seems that
there's a front moving in tomorrow
morning
doesn't look good
so here we are in China at the
University of Nottingham Ningbo campus
we finally arrived and so we're
anticipating this big solar eclipse
tomorrow while we're watching occasional
lightning bolts quite on cue right there
they just cover the entire half of the
sky in the direction where the Sun is
actually supposed to rise tomorrow
morning where we're going to see this
this fantastic astronomical event maybe
so I'm still keeping my hopes up but I'm
not positive that we're actually going
to be able to see it we've been
travelling for two days two and a half I
forget what day it is at the moment but
I know that tomorrow morning at 9:37
a.m. local time is when the big event
happens
well it's for 54 a.m. and we just came
out to see what this guy looks like and
to see what potential is for the solar
eclipse this morning and it doesn't look
very good not very promising indeed
beautiful but not good first Sun for a
solar event we went out for the sunrise
this morning and the weather did not
look terribly fantastic but after a
little break and a cup of tea we came
back out again to see the clouds not
quite so thick and we can actually see
the Sun up there so what I have right
here is my very own solar filter that I
made this is a roll of black and white
film it has to be actually black and
white not the color film that they just
develop black and white but real
black-and-white film so you expose it to
the Sun and then you send it off to be
developed and then it has this nice
layer of silver on there that acts as a
filter for the the ultraviolet and the
infrared that's the most damage most
harmful for your eyes but we have a good
chance of actually getting the solar
clips
okay now I'm really excited yeah in in
10 maybe
10 minutes 10 minutes it'll cover
so we've just reached the first contact
point and that's when the edge of the
Moon first touches the edge of the Sun
so it's now just starting to pass in
front of it
we have about an hour now until the the
total eclipse phase starts so it's the
Sun Moon and Earth in a straight line
the moon actually covers the Sun well it
might seem slow it takes the moon a
while to cover the Sun completely but
actually the shadow of the Moon is
barreling across the surface of the
earth at about 2,000 miles per hour I'm
fascinated by the idea of what ancient
people thought when the Sun just
completely went away there are different
stories about how they reacted the
ancient Chinese in fact thought that
dragons were attacking the Sun then they
were going to eat it and take it away so
what they decided to do was just make
noise beat drums scream make as much
noise as they could to get rid of the
moon and to keep the Sun and so luckily
every time that actually happened and
they got the Sun back Waianae dog named
Bo she want me she want rich answer well
people have just decided to gather to
watch they've been using some of our our
solar eclipse glasses and the kids are
are playing with feathers they don't
really know what's going on they think
the Sun looks like the crescent moon or
they keep saying I see the crescent moon
because the moon is actually covering
the Sun so normally when the the Sun
Goes Down the animals start to go back
to their burrows and go to sleep and so
right now they start to they look like
they are the birds are kind of going
away their small little floaty things
that are leaving and the the Ducks just
started to go hide in the trees but a
couple of kids went and yelled at them
so they didn't really know what to do
that's fantastic
oh it's always fair it's always oh my
gosh oh my gosh this has to be one of
the coolest things I've ever seen you
can see the corona glowing around the
Sun and the temperature just dropped
completely and everyone started cheering
and I completely didn't think we were
going to be able to see it like that
fireworks are going up you can see a
little bit of red at the very edge where
the where we could see the last bit of
light it's amazingly dark when I look
through my binoculars I can actually see
some of the outer rings some of the
corona is sort of flickering and I don't
think that's entirely due to the clouds
I actually think that has something to
do with the light coming out who I mean
can do him could you imagine even
thousands of years ago seeing something
like this and having any idea what was
going on you can hear people yelling in
the distance screaming and cheering huh
oh my gosh if we could actually see if
there weren't any clouds oh we can
there's Venus hey there's Venus so we
can see the planet Venus right there
really bright and if we could see the
clouds around the Sun we'd be able to
see mercury yeah this is amazing this is
amazing the clouds are coming in a
little bit more now so you can't see a
cloud as well but how does this right on
your astronomy experiences I mean even
with the clouds this has to be one of
one of the most phenomenal astronomical
events that you can see with your naked
eye I mean I'm just looking at the Sun
right now it got a little bit brighter
around the edge Oh
and it just doesn't happen very often
and in each spot on the earth oh my gosh
it just popped back out that was a quick
four minutes I have to tell you so the
Sun just popped back out on the other
side of the moon so it's brighter again
instantly so I'm wrapping a foil around
our camera so we can actually look at it
again and now I have to use these the
next total solar eclipse will be in
about one year from now it's July 11th
2010 and it will go past and we'll go
over Easter Island and Chile and some of
Argentina so I have to figure out a good
reason to go down there
so University of Nottingham campus
Easter Island maybe
we're just sitting here glowing with the
enjoyment of what we just saw it's
amazing that four and a half minutes
went so quickly